[موسيقى]
مرحله بناء نموذج الابتكار تنتهي اليوم
والمجموعه المتبقيه
ثمار جهودها لجنه التحكيم جاهزه الدكتور
عبد الحميد الزهيري البروفيسور فؤاد وراء
الدكتور خالد العالي
وبالتاكيد سيرافقنا مقدمه البرنامج غالب
الجمهوري
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته مستقبل
الخير مشاهدينا الكرام واهلا بكم يا عشاق
العلوم 4 مشتركين ضمير ولغايه الان التاهل
لمرحله التقييم الاسواق تصفيات بناء
النموذج تنتهي اليوم وسنعرف من يتاهل
للمرحله التاليه في هذه الليله رافقنا
ايضا ضيف انتقل من الابتكار الى رياده
الاعمال معنا العلوم والحائز على المركز
الثاني في سادس مواز للجم العلوم العماني
سلطان الصبحي
التحديات هي مصنع المبدعين في عمره اثنين
وعشرين تغيرت حياتي بعدما في المركز
الثاني للموسم السنه
[تصفيق]
سمعت في حياتك
على الشارع اليوم من العلوم اجبرني اليوم
يكون مختلف
[موسيقى]
من هذا اليوم توجه عالم رياده الاعمال و
تعبت
المستثمرين يرون في مشروع الان دخلنا في
مجال تنفيذ مشاريع حققته اليوم تتجاوز
الخمسه واربعين
انا لازلت في بدايه
ولكن ي اشوف نفسي في كل شيء طموح ويسعى
لتحقيق
[موسيقى]
السلطان في هذا البيت الذي شهد ولاده
ابتكارك السلطان يشوف ان اكثر ما ختم نجوم
العلوم واستمريت عليه ايضا هو مجال رياده
الاعمال اكثر من ابتكار تشوف ها الشيء
والله في الحقيقه نجوم العلوم كان بالنسبه
ل يعني اه مصلحه مصنع بكل ما يحتمل كان
معنا يعني اعطانا الادوات الفعاله
وعزز ثقتي بنفسي رياده الاعمال تتطلب
مهارات عده منها الثقه بالنفس عاليه وايضا
مهارات فنيه في المجال انه ت تحدثت
الادوات من هذا البيت والحمد لله يعني اخذ
طريق مختلف عن بقيه المشتركين اللي هو
الدخول في عالم رياده الاعمال لازلت في
البدايه والى اكثر من الحمد لله الامور
تتسارع بشكل ملحوظ لا ودينا بنقارن بيقول
سلطان رجل الاعمال والسلطان المبتكر سون
اللقب اللي اه ممكن مبتكر لانه ممكن اي حد
ياخذ يعني اه مميزات رجل الاعمال
والابتكار له خاصيته والابداع اولا يعني
اذا ذلك ان شاء الله كل التوفيق يا سلطان
الافكار هو حصيله جهود متكرره فيها الفشل
وفيها نجاح ايضا امتحان اليوم هو محطه
اساسيه في رحله تحقيق الابتكار مشتركون
الثلاثه الباقون سيتعرفون على مصيرهم
الليله تقرير انتظرنا اليوم وبعد الفاصل
احنا اليوم مش جايين عشان نحقق مع الاخ
عندهم اختراعات
نحكم على النموذج الصناعي
شهرين
[موسيقى]
الاول والثاني والثالث
المجموعه الثالثه تساؤلات كثيره المشروع
الاول
[موسيقى]
مستجدات وتحديات كبيره للحل العالم انا
بقول
فرصه اخذوها
[موسيقى]
انا ب متابعين ايضا على موقع البرنامج
ستكون صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك
انستقرام وتويتر عامل توصيل السلع
والوجبات الى البيوت اصبح مهنه رائجه بعض
الشركات حتى في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تستخدم الربا تبدل الانسان ل
توصيل الطلبات الى المنازل
مراسيم عامل الديليفري اه يصل الى
المستشفى
الروبوت عالم الانسان وبات مسؤولا عن
اعمال روتينيه يوميه والهدف تحرر من اعمال
لا تتطلب مهارات انسانيه مهمه جديده للربط
اوجهها وسيد انا الربو يوزع وجبه الطعام
للمرضى في المستشفيات
اخذ اليا الوجبات من المطار
اسير في اروقه المستشفيات عبر ملاحه جديه
مهمه تسليم الوجبه المناسبه للمريض
المناسب في الوقت المناسب
[موسيقى]
المريض
الاطباء العنايه الصحيه
المهام السنويه
[موسيقى]
يعمل فيها من تكنولوجيا ومعرفه
اضافه
الى
المانيا في
[موسيقى]
المختبر
اصبح
الاكبر هو
المستشفى الاختبارات وداخل الاستوديو
اوليه
والتحدي
هناك في المستشفى مركز الطب والبحوث في
الدوحه
لاجراء التجارب
[موسيقى]
العالم
انا برايي هي الحل الانسب
ما هو انا بس انا بدي
اعطيك على الحل
حسيت بمحل من المحلات انه
زيارته البروفيسور انعكست على وزير
تحديات لم تكن في البيع
وعوده الى حسابات جديده
لانه
شوف الطاوله من عبر التايمز
نعم كثير بس هيدي النقطه بالذات اذا بتطبق
كل الضغط اللي كان عليه
[موسيقى]
الطاوله
بس لما
على الطاوله وحتى الميل
صراحه ما بين وصف سنه اللي بدي اياه
وبنتائج انا شخصيا
الاكل المناسب في الوقت المناسب
الموزع الالي وجبات المرضى وسيم الحريري
واضح من التقرير انه انا معك
وسبب يعني مستويات عاليه من التوتر
يعني فيه كثير عاليه بين اثنين احنا ثلاثه
ما بعتقد كانت فكره كثير يعني
الاقتراح النقطه اللي هي حصل فيها
اه
الوقت للممرضه
على الاسهم بدا
خمس دقائق انا اللي عملته هلا انا
عندي اه
وعندي
مركز
ما يوصل على الكاس عم يقرا
بيعمل
بعدين بيعمل عمليه
بس لما يوصل اول شي ب يتاكد من باركت على
الوضع
احنا لما بنقول عايزين روابط يوم
الوقت
ووطننا احنا
بالعكس
انا بحكي معك الوقت
وتقليل الخطا الانساني بالوقت هداف استر
عن انه
المستشفى ياخذوا
ويمشي فيها بالطرقات
اكيد
[موسيقى]
بالكارثه اللي بياخذها
بيمشي فيها الموظف او الموظفه
خمسطاش
صغيره اللي
اللي بالتيار
اول شي اه انا احترم كثيره اه انا
بالنهايه بس عم بعمل ثلاثه اه غير عاديه
عدد الواجبات دورنا في جيش وال اه الاشياء
الاشياء الثانيه مثل انه
اه هايدا الشيء اذا اذا اكيد بالمستقبل
راح يحمل مش اه مش سته راح يحمل خمسطاش
وعشرين انت ما زلت على موقف
اللي اطلقته الموقف العنيف انه ما في ولا
اسفل على هو
اول شيء فكرت انه
[موسيقى]
بدا
لو انا قلت لك عليه الحديث اربعين بدك
تعمل له ان شاء الله اوكي
يعني بيحمل اربعين اعتبر انه
الغربيه اربعين
لا لا انا
[موسيقى]
اه لانه انا عندي على
الانسان
الوحيد اللي بيفوت على الغرفه وبيوصل الى
طاوله المريض بدون اي تدخل او مساعده من
ايه صحيح
ما هونيك هذا تريد طب هذا الجواب لك
انا
عم جاوبك
احنا يمكن انا بس عشان
على قد ما نطلع من اشاره من اشارات
لان كما حدث تساعد هذه المشكله
انا مشترك فى حاجه مهمه جدا اللي هي في
وقت اللجنه وقت التحكيم ابراهيم اه لما
تحس بصعوبه الهندسه وقت تعرف ان مشروع في
تعقيدات كثيره وايضا حلها الشخص الوحيد
اللي ممكن يحل ها هو انت فيه من خواص نجم
العلوم في جوهرها الرياده وشفنا فيك هذا
الجوهر
تلعب دفاعي وين الهجوم وين اللي هو هذا
الربط واحد اثنين ثلاثه وكان هذا اللي كنا
ندور على
خلينا نشوف الاختبار
املك بعض المناسب للعرب
رب وتوسيع جاهز للتجربه النهائيه بين
مرضاه الاختبار سيكون في مركز السدره للطب
والبحوث في قدر على الروبوت اخذ الطعام من
المطبخ الى الغرفه
ترك المنطقه وجر بيوصل على الاوضاع
وقف بشكل صحيح دون ما يوقع الاغراض وبعدين
راح
الوجبه مضبوطه
منا ولا وده يروح اثنين
وستين اوضاع
وجرى بيفوت على سكان الباسك
يحاول يدخل ما كان فيه صوتي ان الباب مسكر
يفتح الباب
البيت
طاوله قادر يشوف اوروبا عليها
لانه
كثير كثير سهله وانا كنت بالمطبخ والعروبه
المفروض هي الخضره امس بين شهر خمسه
[موسيقى]
انا
الخمسه
طريق التصوير اثر سلبا على فعاليه روبوت
بين المثلث وشكل الكاميرا الرحيم فقررنا
اعاده التجربه بعيدا عن اي عوامل مؤثره
[موسيقى]
اجهزه الملاحه سهلت التنقل في ارجاء
الاوطان واصبحت اليوم رفيق درب المسافر
مشعل سال عن الرفيق قبل الطريق
دوار مشعل يساعد الحجاج في الاماكن
المقدسه
يتوافد ملايين المسلمين من كل انحاء
العالم الى مكه المكرمه لاداء فريضه في
الحرب السلطات السعوديه
مليون ونصف المليون مسلم وصلوا الى مكه
المكرمه
يكون وسطه حرص وجهود تقوم بها جميع الجهات
المعنيه لخدمه ضيوف الرحمان
التنقل بين الاماكن المقدسه قد يكون محيرا
لمن يحج للمره الاولى لتسهيل مناسك الحج
ابتكر مشعل سوارا يستخدم تقنيه البلوتوت
يوجه المؤمن الى الاماكن المقدسه في
السوار وحيد يقود المستخدم الى المكان
المطلوب
بشكل دائم الى مكان اقامه المؤمن
طريقه
داخل الحرم وخارجه
[موسيقى]
اهميه هذا المشروع
فتره طويله
[موسيقى]
البرنامج حريص على دقه الاختبارات
في وقت قياسي جهزت بيئه تحاكم يكون في
الاماكن المقدسه في شبكه استشعار واجهزه
ارشاد ولا سيتي
ليبدا مشعل سلسله تجارب متواصله يجمع فيها
البيانات على مدار
[موسيقى]
اليوم حيكون اول
هايدا
اختبار اليوم
لا الان دور
الطريقه اتخذناها الخير
انا
على روح يعني
هيك
الحياه
اخذناها
صار تعطيني غلط
جربنا مره ثانيه كانت نفس اخطاء الاختبار
الاول
المفروض انه انا اول ما اوصل الخيمه تكون
البريس التي اعطتنا اشاره انه انت وصلت
ولكن من الشارع معناه انه فيه مشكله في
الكويت
صراحه ما بتوقع شيء اكيد صحيح
ام تحت نفسه في مكان
هيك انا اول شيء نعمل
لازم تكون كثيره انا معنديش البوصله
بدون البوصله الجهاز ساعه ما يشتغل مشروع
كله مش ماشي في الطريق الصحيح ولازم اعيد
حساباتي في التصميم لانه تصميمها يختلف
بشكل كبير
مشعل بين ناري التصميم والبرمجه
ومشاكل توجيه تلاحقه في الداخل والخارج
نسبه الخطا قليله نقدر نوصل للحدث
تحديات عليه تغطيها قبل الاختبار النهائي
تعرف الى نظام خاص لتحديد المواقع
سوار الملاحه بالحجاج
مع مشعل الشهراني
اه بحاجه
ما كنت حاجه لا تكون نفسي وكنت عارف على
ان اشغال فيه النادي جيش المالكي يعتمد
على البيت ولا
خيار البلوتوت استاذ يعني هل هو كمان
محكوم بس هو موجود اليوم بمكه المكرمه هو
موجود بالاماكن المقدسه
لانه انت مش ان تعمل كمان بنيه تحتيه على
حسابها لا لا انا ما راح انا مش بيتها كان
اه قله شو الموجود اليوم اللي انت عن ترك
جهاز على البنيه التحتيه الموجوده اللي
موجود في مكان ما راح ركب عليها شيء
سؤال الخيار احدا غير كامله هذا عمل عمليه
الحكومه السعوديه هاي لازم يكون جوابك
صحيح
يعني اليوم
انا انا عندي انا انا فكرت يعني ب بهذا
البعد
من الورقه اللي كان بدها
نظره الى خبره بيشوف اه سكوب ممكن يختلف
عنه وكان اه كانت يعني تدخل اه كثير فائده
كثير المشروع ما اعتقد انه يعني اه هو فات
بساعه كل الجمعه الملاحه الداخليه ضروريه
الضروريه بشكل عام ولو كانت فقط خارجيه
شكلت على شو خارجيه كمان برد مساحتها اكبر
من ال اه
خارجي ما قلت اكثر على ال
مثلا
خارجيه
لا لا انا
الخارجيه الناس كلها
شو بيقول لك
صحيح صحيح ان تدافع عن الخيار
عندك حاجه داخليه حاجه داخلي نعم ان دور
ان دورنا في جيش اليوم انا اقول لك
ما عندي انا
الفلاحه الداخليه والخارجيه
مشعل اظن ان راح يكون لحضور اه ايضا قوي
في النهائي اه تبقى لها بالشيء بسبب واحد
لانه اه انا احب ايضا الجانب الروحاني
والجانب التي راحت على الحاجز
وهايدي مناسبه لالك جدا لانه انت اول مره
اول مره يعني
ما بتعرف
يعني لكن انا عندي بس اه هايدا السؤال
تماما بناء مع هذه الملاحظه اني عندي سؤال
لا لا
اكيد
طبعا انت من من عندك
حتى باتجاه كان تستعملها
واعتبر حال كانت الحجج بدون تشبيه زي اللي
عندي كيف تصرفات هذا الحجم المثاليه
لاستخدام
السوار الشغال وانت بخير الحوالات فيه ضغط
شو وعالم في ضغط
تفضل وانت بتعرف
تفضل كيف بدو يمشي هذا الحج اذا كان هذا
بيتهم
انه
استخدمناها مره وحده وخلاص
يقول لك ان راي التسويه
هو هو هو مساعده مساعده الحج انت بتعمل
كلنا بجيش اللي الخيمه بيوصل
كمان ادرك
زياده من ضمن مثلا في المشاعر المقدسه
احيانا في الليل بعض الناس بيفقد الاساس
الدائره ما يعرف ان الجبل حطيت القبله
انت المتواجد في ال كافه حاليا احيانا
الناس بتضيع كم عدد المطاف
حوالي الكعبه هذا انا اقدر اخليها تحسب
عدد الطوائف اللي انت اخذتم
حسني بالموسم للمعاناه كنت في وتوتر
والصعوبه الكبيره تحت المجهر نتيجه
الاختبار يا اللي صار داخليا وخارجيا
ال وركن برئيس
تمام انظر معنا
هذه هي خارطه الطريق خيمه داخل المبنى
وخيمت ان في الخارج على الجهاز ان يقود
مستخدمه الى الخيمه السياسي
الجهاز
باتجاه
[موسيقى]
ولكن فيتحول الخيمه المكان
يقول انه هذه
على الجهاز ان يوجه الى الخيمه ايه
الاتجاه هذا
انا شايف
هذا ال جيد لكن انا عملت تعبر عن مسار
يعني على المسار
الاتجاه كان مشيت مع الجهاز حتى وصلت في
المنطقه الموجود فيها الخيمه ايه المفروض
هذه الخيمه
وصلت
ولكن بعد سته شويه نحن انتظرنا هناك وكيف
كانش فيه اخيره
هناك مستعمل حقيقي مهم لان يقول هذه
الخيمه تكون الاخرى اذا وصلت على القضيه
اللي تابع لها انا فهذا
مشعل كان الثاني بقى عندنا حسينه من
الجزائر والتي تعتبر اخر الطامحين للتاهل
والتذكير مشترك واحد فقط سيخرج من
المنافسه خلال تصويت لجنه التحكيم فاصل
قصير تتابعون فيها على الثلث استاذ كان
وعلى صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي انستغرام
[موسيقى]
ام
[تصفيق]
الموسم التاسع من نجوم العلوم ومع نهائي
تصفيات تموج الابتكار مجددا مع ضيفنا
العزيز المشترك في الموسم السادس من
برنامج نجوم العلوم والحص المركز الثاني
العماني سلطان الصبحي هيك الاستطاعه الله
اه سلطان بالاضافه الى اعمالك سواء
الابتكاريه او حتى رياده الاعمال جانب من
رياده الاعمال هناك طبعا ال مشروع او
مبادره اه كتانيا والتي تهتم بشكل او باخر
بدعم اه جانب الابتكار وتعزيز الابتكار
لدى الاطفال حدثنا عن بعد برنامج العلوم
اه لما رجعت الى السلطنه كان فيه ضغط على
اه من الكليات والجامعات وايضا اولياء
الامور انه تعالوا ويشرح لنا كيف انت عملت
في البرنامج اه ممكن الدرس اولادنا ممكن
تجيء تعلمهم الى اخره الى اخره انبثقت
الفكره ان يكون مثل مسرح للاطفال اه في سن
مبكر جدا مع بعض ال القطاع الموجوده في
السوق وايضا دمج منهج تعليمي مبسط ولكن
عملي وفعال وشريط ان الناس تحب كل شيء
يكون مختصر وقصير الفكره ان يدرس مفهوم
الابتكار يدرس انه مش فقط هي مشاريع
روتينيه او تلحيم او اه تشغيل الاضاءه لا
ياخذها الى مرحله اللي هو انت انت يعني
يقترعوا يشير اختراع يشتري ووعد بعدين هو
لها الراي انه يكمل فيها يعني رياده
الاعمال والابتكار
ايضا بالشان الاجتماعي مع ال المبادره
يمكن لهم الاستيطان يعني اليوم ربع ساعه
فعلا يعني
عندما الواحد ما ذكر عند التزامات اه
كثيره ممكن اه يعني يلجا اليه الاربعه
وعشرين ساعه ثمانيه واربعين ساعه اشرح لك
لما توجب شيء انت تشتغل فيه ماتحس بالوقت
الشيء الجميل ايضا البيت قريب من المكان
سلطان
الله يارب ان شاء الله كل التوفيق ولكل
مشاركين من جهه العلميه عن كل التوفيق
غالبا ما نرى في الافلام اجهزه ومعدات
تلامس الخيال منها على سبيل المثال للحصر
جهاز بحجم القلم يقوم بفحص طبي شامل في
قوانغ الضعيف فاتحه مع حسين فحص عيون
الاطفال بلا م حتى
[موسيقى]
مع بدايه العام الدراسي يخضع الاطفال لكشف
صحي شامل ودوري للوقايه من مشاكل صحيه قد
تصادفهم ويطال نمو الطفل وفحص الصدر
[موسيقى]
وايضا
وهنا المشكله
تفاعل الطفل مع الفحص غير مقبول والاعتماد
على ما يقوله لا يكفيها شهد كثير لوقت
اضافي والنتائج ليست دائما دقيقه
حسينه وجدت الحل الفحص ال الى ل عيون
الاطفال يقوم جهاز بكشف شامل دون الحاجه
لتفاعل الطفل بعد نتائج خلال دقائق معدوده
يحفظ بيانات الفحص لاستخدامها لاحقا مع
جهاز حسينه تشخيص مبكر لنظر سليم
هذه المنافسه العلميه بامتياز الدوحه يمكن
ان ي من خارج المجال شويه هذا تحدي كبير
اولا لنفسي كلها حد هذا ال هذا المشروع
العيون شعارها منهم لكن يقبلوني لانه
اذا ما في مقابلات بالجزائر مع حكم عيون
انا اللي من هلا راح يكون فيه عندك شهرين
[موسيقى]
بعدها انه هو مشكله حقيقيه
ويمكن هو بدايه
[موسيقى]
في العالم
انظر بعيون كاشفه الفحص لي ل عيون الاطفال
مع حصيله بعشره
حسين ابش اهلا بك
كمان
عشان انت
انت اعطينا بالكاس ان هناك عمليه عيون
الاطفال يعني انت وصلت الى من الاطفال
بكل ما مش مقياس
ماهو فائده
اجراء اختبار ال حول بمساعده هذا ال
البروتوتايب والنموذج النص الصناعي عن
الاختبارات البسيطه التي يجريها الاطباء
جهازي ليس مواجهه الاعتبار ومواجهه
المدارس في العائله الاشخاص العاديين
الهدف من النوم الكشف المبكر العراق يعني
المشاكل التي المبكر بدون الحاجه الى
الاطباء اذا كان فيه
لا انا مش
ساعات كثير بيكون في الاطفال وهو مصدر
بيحصل تشخيص لل لل حول وب تاخرت انه
الغايه ما يروح
مثلا في بلدي انا وين
ان تتوقع
المدرسه مع طبيب المدرسه مفروض يحصل كمان
مع الممارس العام يعني ما فيش ما بيروح
ممارس عام الله في خلال اول صلاه اربع خمس
مرات على الاقل
شخصيا من الحالات
لانك انت انت برات بالطبع
بالمائه واحده
ان يصير في دول موسم يعني فيه فيه ضغط
وفيها مع بعض
لكن الكره سببت يعني ربك زياده للمشترك ال
غير واثق من نفسه ولكن اللي فعلا هو عند
المعلومات وادى فحسب بل اي مشكله
خلفيه خلفيه
المفترض نحنا الجنه حصار لانه الفرنسي
للولد اصدقاء الاطفال صرحنا من
الميكانيكيه المايكرو الالكتروني اللي هو
بالسبعينات يعني مثل اليوم في السبعينات
السبعينات شيء اسمه
او الالكتروني كلانس يا اللي هي بتعمل
تقريبا تجنب لكل الادوات الميكانيكيه
وصارت الالكتروني كلمتين امل شيء لانه عصر
المبكر والكترونيت نحنا اليوم بعصر
انا اللي شايفه هلا امام هون فيك تقولي لي
ليش نحنا بالالفين وسبعه عشر سنه تقريبا
على الميت اللي هي مايكرو لاند الالكتروني
فلان سموها باخذ السبعينات والثمانينات من
السنتر الماضي
شو اللي صار نحنا اليوم بالالفين وسبعه
عشر مع الزكاه الاصطناعي مع الانترنيت
يا اللي بيقول لك تقول انها تكنولوجيا
الفين وسبعه
هذا العصر اليوم
ما استفدت من كل المعلومات الموجوده على
تليفون الزكي اللي حمله انا ما ما ما عم
نستفيد من كل شيء في معلومات
وخبره موجوده على الانترنيت صارت فيها
وتستفيد منها بالبر اساسيه في المستقبل
مع الجهاز
في تطبيق
يعني النتيجه هو ما بيشوف ها الولد الولد
هايذه
على على صوره حلوه
بعض
بيكون على التطبيق ال ال
ال او
النتيجه نحنا عم نحكي فقط
تحولت هذا الجهاز مفيد لي مع انه انا فيني
يطلع هلا
بس ما بعرف درجه
يعني اذا بدنا اللي انا في نشوف وبعيوني
ما بدي
اوكي ايه درجات من حول يللي غير ظاهره
للبشر
لكن اليوم كانت فعاله
دقيقه وقاسيه ايضا على اه المشتركين ولكن
انا حاضر اظن ان هذا هو الاسلوب الامثل
اللي مفروض اللجنه التابعه معاي مشتركه
الاطفال
لانه
في ضغط نفسي
يعني
الكلمات مني اه بكلمات من الشخص
انه يصل المدارس منشان يعملوا فحص اجباري
يعني
اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه
بكل عناوين عريضه كان الله عليك
الانتخابات الجزائريه خلينا نشوف شو صار
الاختبار وهذا اختبار طبى واختبار عيون
بفتكر
ادى اكبر منه ولا عمرك
ما عندنا اربعه وعشرين
حسين لاثبات فعاليه جهازها عشرين فحصا
تقليدي لعيون سته اشخاص احنا اليوم بنا من
فحص حول على الكبار من عنده من نفس الفحص
على الاطفال
روايات انتهينا من مخصصه الت حالات والذين
في حالات فيهم حوالي ثلاث حالات طبعا ال
اه لحظه الحسم عون الاشخاص انفسهم لتجربه
جهاز حصيله املين بنتائج مماثله
[موسيقى]
في مشكل
الدفاع حسين اعطانا
عند الحكيم كما نعطي
بالدفاع سبعه حسين اعطانا كمان عندنا
اعطانا كمان
انترنت اكس التوفيق الكيس ترى الدفاع
حسينه
عند الدكتور اعطتنا سنته بما انه بس تبع
حسينه رئيسه
اربع مرات التحليل اللي بتكون عن بعد
يا ما بتشوفهم
ما كان فيه تواجد في عندنا تحليلين اعطتها
سبعه حسين
وهناك ان هناك اذا كان التحليل هو عن
السويس ان جينرال في تحليل راح يكون
واضح ان التوتر هو القاسم المشترك بين
المتنافسين الجميع ينتظر لحظه الحسم قبل
التصويت النهائي الفاصل تابعونا فيه عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي فيس بوك تويتر
انستقرام وحيث تعلم وقعنا
خليكم معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تعرفون جيدا ان مشتركا
واحدا من الثلاثه راح غادرنا اليوم وقرار
لجنه التحكيم
لا مفر من من سيستمر معنا في مرحله تقييم
الاسواق ومن سيغادر القرار النهائي الان
عند اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
التركيه الثلاثه تفضل
[موسيقى]
كل واحد منكم عندها طبعا
التوتر واعتقد انه راح تشترك الكره من
يدكم اليوم اعضاء لجنه التحكيم
احنا نحافظ على الكره تستهلك بشكل كبير
التصويت عندك
[موسيقى]
شكره لاعضاء لجنه التحكيم
نتائج الان يا مشعل يا وسيم ما صارت جاهزه
انت على طبق الذهبي الى المرحله المقبله
الله العالم
اللي قاعد فكره للحجاج يا مشعل راح يوصل
كانت فعليا الى المرحله المقبله والضغط
معلوم ان يؤثر بشكل كبير على العين
لكن نتمنى لكم جميعا السلامه والوصول الى
المرحله المقبله بسلام واحد بس راح راح
اعطيكم النتائج بالارقام بس بدون الاسماء
الاول حصل على سته وثمانين الثاني واحد
وثمانين فاصله سبعه المركز الثالث وثمانيه
وستين فاصله
المركز الاول في احد المجتهدين منكم
نقول مبروك اللي
مشعل من السعوديه
[تصفيق]
واحد راح يغادر واحد راح يبقى وسيم ان
توقعت الاطباق من خلال جهاز سيوقع كانت
ايضا
فشل مرتين من اصل اربعه حسينا وعندنا
كرسيين بس واحد من المراحل الثاني هل
سيكون كرسيك انت وسيم نقول مبروك
للقادم من المانيا وسيم من لبنان دكتور
الجمهور
اكثر هنالك
خارج اسوار برنامج نجوم العلوم شكرا جزيلا
لك على مثابرتك وعلى جهدك اللي بدات
تصفيات هذه المرحله مشاهدينا الكرام انتهت
مرحله جديده تنطلق مرحله تقييم الاسواق
المتاهلون سيقودون تجربه نفسها الاسبوع
المقبل
تابعونا عبر موقع البرنامج
وال صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر
وانستقرام اما الان استودعكم الله مثل ما
راح بوتين على ال ود دائما
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نعم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم يعني ما شاء الله كانت قويه
الشخصيه ثانيه
لكن الا بعد طبعا عند نقطه البدايه
[موسيقى]
على حساب معناتها
حسينا بالنسبه الى تعتبر روح اللاعب اللي
كنا بيشتغل فيه اتمنى على التوفيق متاكد
مستقبلها راح يكون
اثنين
[موسيقى]
ام